we're getting mcdonald's for dinner no
we're not
it's pride month you're being homophobic
babe i'm gay too
okay this isn't the oppression olympic
hello to anyone editing this
my name is ian hi buzzfeed i'm chris
and i'm ian and we're gonna answer some
questions for you here we go
our first viral video that hit about
nine million views i don't think anyone
asked for that
but that's i'm kidding our first viral
video was like hey why don't you get me
we have to get each other get get get
get
and people would say ceo of get our
first viral video was
me asking ian can we have kids i was
saying i'm gonna do the gay
take on all of these straight couple
challenges
and i wasn't expecting it to really blow
up i thought it was a fun video but i
didn't think this is
genius and this is going to blow like
blow everyone out of the water
and then we were at dinner at a friend's
house and i remember checking my phone
midway through and being like
whoa that has a lot more views and then
checking it five minutes later and
saying
whoa that has a hundred thousand more
views and i just checked five minutes
ago and seeing like
a thousand more followers in the past
five minutes so that
was like one moment when i was like wow
this video is going big but
i think we only really thought it was
one big video
we didn't expect everything to change
from that moment on like i i was doing
these challenges on him but life was
very much
normal we were saving all of our money
at that time we were just
trying to get through this pandemic i
was feeling creatively parched
and i just remember it was like okay
like he would
do these things and catch me saying
something ridiculous
i was just so bored i needed to be
creative
yeah remember my cousin was well both of
my cousins were
with us the first few days that things
were really happening for us
and they were just thinking how we're
talking about how cool it was and like
my dad kept asking me for updates on
like my numbers because he's a very
numbers guy so he's definitely a family
invested thing and a lot of my family
was like we always knew this was gonna
happen for you
my parents were not that my
sister and her kids my nieces were the
ones who made me feel kind of cool about
it right yeah
but then my mom the the time it kind of
hit
her that oh you're doing something
special was when we did an interview
with katie uh
um congressman congressman or yeah or
senator
representative katie porter yeah um
right before the election or during
election time and my mom was like wow
that was that's really cool
i thought that was um pretty appropriate
of course the parents were reacting to
that
tremendously we moved cross-country from
new york
where i had lived for a very very long
time and um
that's almost slightly british for a
very very long time literally
and then we moved here to the west coast
in los angeles life has changed so much
when we started i was
i still had my senior year of college to
finish so
i finished my senior year of college
from la
um online just graduated just graduated
whatever and i was like so
life is so different than i ever thought
it would have been when i graduated i
expected to move to new york and
audition for broadway
and now i'm here filming a video for
buzzfeed
i don't think there is an answer to that
because you can go viral
doing a dance and being like the
character of yourself
you can go viral singing i think it
really is it's
it's really more up to the universe than
it is to you the universe will show you
what you can go viral for
yeah okay i'll give you today a dream
collab i want to do something with paula
abdul
love her and i did not realize how
immersed in artists life she would like
yes her herself and like
all of her music and anything she danced
in but she choreographed
four icons she choreographed for janet
jackson which i just learned about
and there's this video i'm just like
that's what i want to do i would love to
learn one of her dances
by her and tape that always a dream
collab
for me is lady gaga i just need to
have her creatively in the same space as
me
once in my life um i
will be the coffee runner for her and
that is that i would consider
a collab i'd be like i collabed with
lady gaga i got her coffee order in the
morning i will do
literally whatever it takes to be in a
room with her one day that would
actually be a funny tick tock if
if like she reached out and she's like
okay like you get one video what would
it be and you're like okay so you're
just gonna ask me to go get coffee for
you and i will go get it and i'm gonna
come back and you're gonna just say
that's all maybe that would go viral
yes yes we have been recognized in
public separately together
quite a bit quite a bit especially as
things have started to open up and we've
opening up and we've been able to leave
the house more i'd say we get recognized
especially if we're together
every time we go out just us yeah yeah
they usually recognize me first and then
they're like oh who's that guy he's with
no wrong no they see this strapping
young lad and then they're like oh who's
that grandfather he's with no maybe the
first one was right
all of the interactions we've been very
lucky to have
very wonderful interactions with anyone
who's spoken to us
i think people have become very nice we
haven't really
knock on wood gotten like a stalker or
something like that
everyone's been wonderful and i really
enjoy someone coming up and sharing
their experience with me
and he's better about that me being able
to
tell them my gratitude for them for
watching our videos and kind of being
there
for me from afar yeah i had one little
weird encounter i was in miami and
restrictions were starting to get lifted
and i went
to i was a guest of a friend's birthday
gathering so i didn't really know anyone
and it was the first time i had been
outside with like people
while uh while kobe was still kind of in
this murky land whatever
um and a group of
fans came up to me and i don't know i
was like friends
fans um we're like oh my god it's like
it's you
and they were they were so excited and
that they were like where's chris oh my
god like are you guys fighting
did you guys break up like in that order
in that way that they were just like
assessing me and that
that was weird because it was just like
no i'm by myself and you know we travel
alone anyway
yeah that was the weirdest moment of
just like feeling
slightly uh i was over
overstimulated by that there aren't too
many i hate there are
a lot that just gets stuck in my head
into the thick of it
into the thick of it into the thick of
it
who is your favorite tick-tocker at the
moment
[Music]
me it's right here oh that was so sweet
oh my god mine would probably be
um careful
well no but you'll like this one i
honestly think
one person whose videos i love watching
right now are happy kelly
oh yeah um yeah she is just so
full of joy and her page is so colorful
i love i know that's what i've noticed
this
is
so colorful and well put together and
all of her videos are like
15 seconds or less so they're just very
satisfying to watch very satisfying
i yes absolutely
love you happy kelly she's amazing
leggings
the leggings or that heated blanket we
haven't used it recently
you got it from tic-tac-toe well we got
it we did our target challenge
and i got that as part of the target oh
i see oh okay so i guess it wasn't from
tick tock but i was thinking it was
involved with the tick tock we did
so i bought it for tick tock just
meeting a bunch of
amazing creators and really cool disney
events those are
kind of my my most fun yeah we got to go
to the opening
of disneyland a re-opening of disneyland
and that was
really really cool yeah do things that
you love to do
throw spaghetti at the wall and see what
sticks yeah and don't let views or likes
be the driving force they feel good
obviously because if it's being received
well in that way and there's
always support on tick tock which is
what i love about tick tock
but just train yourself to make
something and put it out in the world
and keep doing what you want because
that is what will drive you on the days
that maybe you're feeling a little
uninspired or you're feeling unmotivated
if it's something you're passionate
about and love doing that's what will
pick you up and make you keep pushing
forward and doing it there have been
plenty of times when i've wanted to just
like
throw my arms up in the air because i
have no idea what kind of video i want
to make or how i'm supposed to keep this
going
and because i loved it because i had
some sort of passion about it i came up
with some
cool fun things that ended up being
received well because i loved it so much
you keep doing the same thing yeah you
literally just do the exact same thing
you just you you continue doing the
the thing that you felt like was well
received and then you and and you morph
and you evolve yeah
and and you hopefully don't just do that
one thing
it grows and it and it stimulates like
differently every time in some sort of
way
if you have the goal of being someone
with a large following or something like
that
if you see something as well received
figure
out why that was well received and then
keep doing it and
and make it even better i'm also a big
fan of
if there's something that the audience
is connecting with whether it's
just you as as your soul and or the
or content um me as a viewer i
appreciate
uh a sense of production behind
something so like
um when something is well made and
there's
and it feels like there's been thought
attached to it
i uh i'm gonna be drawn to this person
as a creator because i appreciate
and can see that they took some time to
uh write this funny skit out or do you
know and like the cuts
like i appreciate seeing how everyone
creates
and it's like it's it's not just like
what they're saying it's how they made
it
is also a part of their point of view so
just keep experimenting
in that way yeah well i went to school
for being an actor so my hope is to be
able to
use my degree and act at some point in
my life
off of my phone um in front of a real
camera
even even if i am lucky enough to do it
i will always have the goal of just
wanting to do more and more and more i
just love
art and consuming it and also
taking part in it and making it so i'd
love very good at it
thank you thanks you're welcome
what's what's a goal for yourself oh a
big goal that i have for myself
i would like to be a director um or
choreographer
i would say in some ways just as you
i am an actor on my phone you are
already a
director choreographer i do it yeah i
like do it in
like micro doses in in everyday life for
sure
but i would like to be given the
opportunity or make my own opportunity
um i guess we're kind of already doing
it yeah we we are
we're doing it on a tick tock scale so
yeah uh
that's that would be very cool to to
direct a group of actors
yeah behind the camera thanks buzzfeed
this was lovely
this was great
[Music]
you